foreign
slow down the snoring a little bit here
um it's not me it's her I I believe me I
know um
wakeful snoring is not in your skill set
no no I'm working on it you don't need
to it's sort of we're good
um transgender studies quarterly
is
described as here's just the first
sentence in about the journal over the
past two decades transgender studies has
become fertile ground for new approaches
to cultural analysis so sorry second
sentence tsq transgender studies
quarterly offers a high profile venue
for Innovative research and scholarship
that can test the objectification
objectification pathologization and
exoticization of transgender lives
okay so what do they publish well
one of their first pieces that they
published in their very first issue is
titled
trans species
and it has the following quote not yet
um yeah more recently
Ernst Myers well-known 1942 biological
definition of species as quote actually
or potentially integrating natural
populations which are reproductively
isolated from other such groups and
quote while contested
helped solidify heterosexuality's
starring role in species debates
there are a lot of species Concepts out
there for those of us who have actually
thought carefully about what a species
is and isn't and whether or not it is a
necessary conceit or an actual thing and
reasonable people can disagree about the
answers to these questions and for those
of us who have actually also considered
many species Concepts including which
ones work best for extinct species
versus extinct species asexual species
versus sexually reproducing species
plants versus animals all the things
okay yes
Ernst Meyer who
in 1942 proposed what is the most
commonly known and most commonly used uh
species concept for those do for those
trying to figure out what species are in
extant Animal Land
uh is about actually potentially
integrating natural populations which
are reproductively isolated
has
nothing to do with solidifying
heterosexuality's starring role in
species debates because what it is is
actually trying to get to a definition
that is scientifically useful so that we
can do phylogenic analysis and
understand who was more closely related
to whom this this this this movement of
I um okay go I I I I I yeah I know
you're about to boil over here like I'm
gonna sound like a teenage girl here but
I I can't even yeah I can't [ __ ] even
at this point and I haven't even gotten
to the next one yet it's even worse than
that right this is the theme for this
theme
okay the idea that what is being
centered is
heterosexuality in species definitions
no heterosexuality is Central to
reproduction that's what happened here
right the idea that there are species it
doesn't matter where you fall out on
trans activism you don't have species
without reproduction which does require
a certain amount of heterosexuality some
species are asexual well some species
are asexual and some fungus have many
many mating types etc etc etc within
animals yes within animals which is to
say for at least the last 500 million
years which is actually smaller than
animals with invertebrates so probably
for one to two billion years we have
been we are within a lineage that it has
binary Sexes and reproduce by putting
one of each together
okay within vertebrates we can say for
sure that that is uninterrupted in our
lineage there has never been a moment in
our lineage since we've been vertebrates
that we our lineage has opted for
asexuality and then gone back or more
than two never more than two in our
lineage nope didn't happen not a
possibility sorry I don't care if you
think you're a fungus you're not
um yeah so all right this journal
the um transgender studies quarterly
yeah transgender gender studies
quarterly of which uh Paisley Cara who
has a starring role in the journal
Nature this week is a founding co-editor
yes so this is a classic case of what
years ago I called ideal laundering
right where you want to take an idea
that is nonsense
and you want to give it the veneer of
legitimacy that comes from putting it
through the
um
the trappings of scientific publication
right so there's obviously no standard
of logic here right there's nothing
these are just simply assertions that
aren't true and don't make sense that
are being dressed up as if they have
been through some sober process of
evaluation which they haven't clearly
and what's worse okay it's one thing
when that happens in
in trans gender studies quarterly
transgender studies quarterly but this
is the exact moment at which this goes
from
the friends Fringe nonsense Journal
to the premier science journal Nature
right right and not only that
it's worse than that too because the
email that you received that gave you a
little tour of important things taking
place in nature this week email from
nature yes email from nature
juxtaposes it with an apology for having
contributed in the past to uh racist
ramblings of people who should have
known better at least if there had been
modern right which undoubtedly there is
a lot of that in Nature's history that
is uh in fact an embarrassing fact of
Science and the fact that science is a
self-correcting process is the only
thing that that rescues it but and
certainly we shouldn't be pretending
it's not right but the point is to say
we are really sorry for screwing up the
science and allowing people's prejudices
to fly uh under a scientific Banner in
our journal and then the next headline
is that exactly and it's not as if this
is victimless right this is obviously
trampling the right of as you point out
gay people and women yes yes so and now
children because children are being
mutated permanently mutilated right so
the point is at what may be you know the
low water mark in the last
7 500 years for the journal Nature with
respect to its contributing to the
discrimination against innocent people
right it is simultaneously doing that
and apologizing it apologizing for it in
the past needlessly because we all
understand that it has taken place and
that you know History of Science
includes an awful lot of bad science and
Prejudice it's like nature is going like
we are so good at seeing what everyone
has already pointed out
and we are really bad at seeing what a
lot of people are pointing out but the
ideologues won't let us say and to have
those two things in Counterpoint with
one another in one of the world's two
premier science journals tells us that
science is in deep trouble
yes deep trouble this is look this is a
game of capture yeah and something
nakedly political has idea laundered in
Fringe journals and it is now captured a
premier journal and in some sense
apologizing for the past wrongs of that
journal at the same time that it is
championing new wrongs is the story
right nature is captured and frankly
we've been warning about this remember
the uh
shut down stem campaign oh yes well
they've shut down stem that was right
after uh George Floyd died and many of
the cities in the Western World had gone
into
protests that had gone violent that had
become riots right yeah so
um clearly the thing that you need to do
at that moment is shut down stem shut
down stem and you know I don't think
people understand in general how
dependent they are on a yes admittedly
flawed but functional scientific
apparatus functional governance
apparatus functional public health
system and when these things get
captured
right yes it's all
very fascinating but worse than that
it's extremely dangerous right how for
example were there to be a global
pandemic would we navigate it if our
science journals had been captured by
trans activists
right that's where we are and that's so
I got one more thing on tsq transgender
studies quarterly but that's where we go
next in fact a little bit
um
I didn't read any complete articles in
transgender studies quarterly I couldn't
I couldn't do it but I did read a number
of abstracts and I skimmed a number of
pieces
I can't say I learned anything
but here's another article that I ran
into
I'm going to have Zach put the abstract
up on the screen it's a it's called a
research article do you know not quite
yet it's called a research article it's
from May 2017. every time the word trans
is used it has an asterisk after it but
for ease of reading I'm going to lie the
asterisk I don't know what that's
supposed to signify
the title of this piece is called is the
title of this piece is the transness of
Blackness the Blackness of transness
and it's by someone named Marquis Bay or
maybe it's Marquis Bay I don't have any
idea now you can put up the abstract and
I will read it
yes
the asterisk in the middle of transness
oh yes
yes trans transasterisk dashness maybe
it is sacredness
the essay thinks the essay also not this
essay the essay
the Royal essay I guess the essay thinks
radically differently about the concepts
of black and trans trans and black thus
denote poetic para ontological forces
that are only tangentially and
ultimately arbitrarily related to bodies
said to be black or transgender
that is to say they are differently
inflected names for an an original
lawlessness that marks an escape from
confinement and a besidedness to
ontology
manifesting in the modern world
differently as race and gender
fugitivity black and trans though
pointed out by bodies that identify as
black or trans precede and provide the
foundational condition for those
Fugitive identificatory demarcations
the author seeks to demonstrate the ways
in which trans is black and black is
Trans in what ways and to what extent is
there a Blackness present within
transness and vice versa
what is the effect of these Analytics
this essay hopes to address these
questions but also leave them suspended
in black Trans
minality
[Music]
it's good it's good and it's like oh my
God dare oh it's so good they're daring
you to point out that that is not
it doesn't actually even mean anything
it just it's it's it it is it is at best
bad poetry
it's folk on poetry I know it makes me
want to jump out of an airlock when I
read this but my favorite sentence I
think in this is oh they are trans and
black are differently inflected names
for an an original lawlessness that
marks an escape from confinement and a
poseidoness to ontology well I actually
kind of agree with that
I don't think it means anything but I
agree with its meaninglessness oh my God
so
the co-founding editor of this journal
of the journal in which this was
published and know the co-founding
editor of a journal is not responsible
for everything that is published in it
whereas that that line about Mar and
about the the biological species concept
was in the opening uh volume the opening
issue so I do think that Paisley Quran
can be held responsible for that maybe
he can't be responsible for this but uh
frankly uh I would hold Paisley Cara
responsible for the whole thing because
for what reason nature did you give this
person with negative scientific
credibility a giant platform in your
esteemed but not for very much longer
publication
foreign
[Music]